sarah i will come to you first with this
one i'm wondering when you first pitched
the season to amazon what was the road
map for the show what did you have in
mind in terms of you know things like
how many seasons and did you have a
loose idea of maybe where you wanted it
to end i think i pitched a four season
arc um so intent amazon
[Laughter]
and i always had in my mind loose
vignettes i mean this is a coming-of-age
story so when you're crafting that i
think it's important to have the
beginning of immaturity and then like
the coming of age the actual
metamorphosis in the chrysalis moment
and then the coming like of age coming
out of that into
some kind of adulthood or more maturity
we want to tell that whole story so i
didn't so much think of how gretchen's
conspiracy would devolve but i
definitely did craft vignettes of each
character for what i wanted
to see from them um as they emerged from
coming of age how this experience formed
them
that kept me focused on the character
level um because i knew we could
manipulate the conspiracy um how how we
needed um and how we thought gretchen
would go forward with that
all right amy i'll throw this one to you
now so did the response to season one
change anything in terms of what you all
had planned for season two whether it's
you know due to something you yourself
learned while making season one or
something that viewers really responded
to that you decided you wanted to lean
into more well first off i think i was
um
so i'm such a scared worrier um and
assuming especially in today's tv
landscape that there will be not only
will there not be like any groundswell
like there'll be nobody watching and you
have no impact
um sarah in the room would sometimes say
like i hope if there's fan art and i
would just be like oh
there's like we're we're going to be
lucky if anybody so the thrilling thing
to see not only was their fan art but
then people started doing fan art of us
i was so blown away by the response and
so touched and thrilled
um that we had
spoken to the audience which is all you
ever want to do as writers of television
is actually
have people feel moved by it
i think
for me having done this before and had
fans come to a show i think um i really
wanted to be sure
however it went we really just stayed
true to our vision of what the show was
because i think people came to the show
because
sarah built these very deep characters
that we continued to grow and make
deeper as the season went on
um and then i thought our job in this
season was we were adding eight new
characters was to honor those characters
in the same way and to just continually
deepen
um our female relationships and what
they were going through as a team and
then to explore these new characters and
obviously shoney became
something we uh you always hope but we
hadn't expected that um so i think sarah
says this like we come in every day
making sure we're we were honoring those
uh women and sort of what they had come
to mean to the fans great success in
that respect so one of my absolute
favorite things about your show is how
many incredible young actors that it's
introduced me to and a lot of them are
getting their first screen credits here
so for both of you i was curious
why do you feel that it was important to
find newer talent and fresh voices
rather than you know when you get an
opportunity to make a season two of an
amazon show building your ensemble with
more familiar faces that you know could
bolster the star power of the show in
that sense i think certainly in the
first season and as well as in the
second um
we wanted the characters themselves to
be extremely extremely relatable we're
trying to reflect reality as much as we
can um you know anyone um you know that
i don't know has too
huge of a profile i think would have
um i don't know maybe thrown the balance
off um among the casts um and so you
know finding these uh fresher faces
um this untapped talent um has
allowed them to really like be just as
they're thrown onto the island a lot of
them have been thrown into this you know
experience of making a television show
and it actually reflects beautifully on
screen that how it resonates actor to
character it's like oh this newness all
this
and it really it sort of shows up on
screen in the most beautiful way um and
it's just a thrill to find someone you
know and you're you're nervous but then
they just bloom um it's such a joy
radiates off screen and it hits our
level because it's the it's like an
absolute joy to see a show and to see
someone you've never seen on screen
before and then i like feel the urge to
keep following them no matter what
projects they go on to next i love it
i have to say just as a shout out like
our casting director deanna
without her skill her beautiful skill
set of both finding these new talents
and then working with them so we knew
even before we got them onto the island
of australia and
the islands that we were creating
we had such confidence in um the people
we were choosing even though a lot of
them didn't have the experience because
she's just brilliant all right this is
like my big burning question here
because this is what i was most nervous
about going into the news the new season
so i was very excited about the idea of
meeting the group that was uh the
twilight of adam but i got like a little
nervous at the end of the season that oh
no if you add a whole other group of
characters i'm not gonna have enough
time with the original ensemble so what
was the key to not just you know
balancing those two groups of characters
but also the third that operate this
whole thing and work in the bunker well
i think when we were boarding the
stories it's just like you have to look
at the grid and be like you know are our
women getting the richness the storiness
the storylines that they deserve and
that will continue to
engage the fans and and also they're
just never going to leave our hearts and
minds as the originators and the sort of
soul of the show um so we just were very
intentional about that and i think we're
sort of in a weird way gretchen sarah
and i and this this is the only way
we're like gretchen um the story of the
women is sort of what inspired the show
so the boys are the control groups so
even when you're watching the boys
i think you're thinking oh the women
found water this way and oh they found
sustenance this way
so the boys become a real counterpoint
to the girls so i think it really allows
uh the audience to feel like even when
you're with the boys you're sort of
watching them
in comparison and counterpoint to the
women you've already fallen in love with
it's especially well done and effective
you knocked it out of the park again i
have like a mile long list of questions
i could take up your entire day but i
have to let you go huge congratulations
on the wild season too
you